بدات في اثيوبيا اعمال الدوره الثانيه
والاربعين للمجلس التنفيذي للاتحاد
الافريقي على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه في
العاصمه في العاصمه الاثيوبيه تاتي اعمال
هذه الدوره تمهيدا لانعقاد القمه
الافريقيه السادسه والثلاثين المقرره
السبت المقبل وتبحث اجتماعات الدوره جدول
الاعمال والقرارات المقترحه لقمه الرؤساء
التي تاتي تحت شعار تسريع تنفيذ منطقه
التجاره الحره القاريه كما يناقش
المجتمعون ملفات سياسيه وامنيه عده ابرزها
التقدم الذي احرزته مبادره اسكات البنادق
لتسويه صراعات القاره وامكانيه حصول
افريقيا على مقعدا دائما في مجلس الامن
الدولي
المقر الاتحاد الافريقي في اديس ابابا
مراسلنا عبد القادر اعراض عبد القادر ما
هو الموضوع على جدول هذه الدوره الثانيه
والاربعين للمجلس التنفيذي للاتحاد
الافريقي
نعم سلمى يمكن اختصار المشهد هنا في اديس
ابا في العاصمه الاثيوبيه في اننا نعيش
قمه افريقيه تمتد لخمسه ايام اليوم وغدا
هو اجتماع المجلس التنفيذي لوزراء
الخارجيه لاقرار مختلف التوصيات والاوراق
التي عكف دبلوماسيون على اعدادها
لاسابيع لم نقول لشهور وهنا ربما الصعوبات
تكمل في التفاصيل في انتظار ما سيتسرب من
هذه الاجتماعات المغلقه
عقد الاجتماع الاول وسيعقد لاحقا اجتماع
ثاني خلال هذا اليوم ابرز الملفات ترتبط
بثلاث عناوين رئيسيه التكامل الاقتصادي
ومنطقه التجاره الحره ما الذي تحقق منها
نحن نتحدث عن سوق اذا ما تحقق يعني تقريبا
تريليونين و500 مليار دولار وايضا هذا
فيما يتعلق بالتكامل الاقتصادي موضوع
النزاعات والخلافات وهنا
خبر مهم جدا يتعلق بوصول وزيره خارجيه
بوركينا فاسو الى القمه لماذا بوركينا
فاسو لانها ضمن الدول التي عاقبها الاتحاد
الافريقي بعدم حضور القمه بسبب الاوضاع
غير الدستوريه كما يقول اتحاد الافريقي
يرتقب خلال اجتماع مجلس الامن
ومجلس السلم والامن بعد غد ان يتم تداول
وضعيه عدد من الدول اضافه الى ذلك هناك
ثلاث دول وهي غينيا وبوركينا فاسو وماري
تقدمت رسميا بطلب الى الاتحاد الافريقي
تطالبه برفع هذه العقوبات وتمكينها
بالحضور هذه القمه طبعا في انتظار تطورات
في هذا الاطار الجانب الاخر يرتبط في هذه
القمه والمحور الثالث يتعلق باجنده 2063
هذه القمه ستدرس ما الذي تحقق بعد عشر
سنوات من اقرار هذه الاجنده وتسطير محاور
الاجنده الجديده العشر سنوات الجديده هناك
حضور دولي لافت يعكس حاله التنافس في
القاره الا روسي امريكي صيني ولكن ايضا
هناك حديث للمسؤولين في القاره الافريقيه
في الاتحاد الافريقي عن تجنيب افريقيا
حاله الاستقطاب التي يعيشها العالم
والحديث عن رؤيه جديده للقاره الافريقيه
على الاقل هذا ما لمسناه لدى حضورنا اليوم
في الجلسه الافتتاحيه وكلمه رئيس المفوضيه
موسى فقي شكرا لك اذا عبد القادر عراضه
مراسلنا من اديس ابا